singing what's a and Oh fee a little
kitty
you are so cute yes you are so pretty
when I do that you'll know that you get
box to reach the time I change your
litter box you oh you look surprised
you're from a little bitty nose of
America Canada Nova Scotia huge emotion
I want to tell you dance thanks guys and
when original I was a schuhplattler
schuhplattler is a dance in Germany we
will not see it now I shall stand and
show you but it's like that you know
watch out big fall so it's like the
doctor but do these things sorry buddy
but yeah so I start with this and then I
start to make some DJ times so I was a
DJ making things in Germany until now
realize I want to spread my music to all
of the world you know try not just like
II along in my tiny town or like my
uncle my uncle birthday party or
something you know that's like eight
people you know I want to do it like
eight eight billion people so Los
Angeles is a place to do it so I'm here
now to spread all of my things hello my
name is fula and this is a song about
bananas
my party music can be from anything that
you life sometimes I shall go to a party
and I you know forgetful Johnson did
forget something and so they can give to
me too is I did one time to a party
trust with glasses and glasses so a man
my glasses and then glasses and then I
have my and I make a sound and I make a
hole like like a concert you know live
two years and I'm tried very much I I
think I shall be here a little bit you
know going back and forth because here
dislike a place where I may share my my
things with everybody my music and my
videos and all of these things it's like
Los Angeles is it's like a megaphone you
know like I'm a tiny person who can hear
me you know but then I come here
Los Angeles is like the megaphone all
the people you know the city is a crazy
place you know there is no sight walking
for humans you know if you like I'm not
an automobile I want to go to the stop
you cannot go no place you just stay in
a tiny room watch a television call the
pizza place you know so you need some
cause so I I learned this also it is a
little more warm here many times so I'm
not prepared as you can see I'm sweating
like an old man in a sauna and this is
always what is occurring here is I am
NOT prepare my body my body was not
raising this there talking in one say
about Jennifer oh I tell you Jennifer
she is she is really a party pooper
Jennifer poops at parties because I do
not know these as a baby as a child you
know in Germany we have seas we have
some of course we say strange things to
people but I did grow up as a seven oh
dear boy and I did know those but now I
come here and people are talk about put
your fish in a barrel shoot it you know
or like look at that it's a daddy's
longlegs what you know it like a tiny
synapse it blows up in my head when I
hear this and so I don't understand
sometimes it is like is it real it's a
party really is a someone really go to
the party for pooping just really is
occurring you know or is it just people
say ders and then I say who is doing
this if she really make do it presently
go we do not need this this is an
excellent party look nice music oh we
are watching a film and then she go and
do it it is so hard here I'm learning
now in America England do you have some
of these yeah so many of these yeah like
it's 10 billion trillion and people here
they speak sometimes only with city do
it's like a sentence can be like hey
what cracking I'm good look at the jaw
its float look at the camera it broke it
back and destroy hey what is this really
but I understand from Germans like hello
how are you today I am good are you
hungry forever spy it's tough for me and
people always are saying hey thula
you're English sometimes it is terrible
and sometimes it is very terrible you
know why is this occurring and I think
for me it is like if I'm a tired person
then my English is it's terrible because
my brain cannot make the translate
translate translate or forget it I just
spit out words I may understand you know
but to learn is tricks for me because
I'm always go back forth back forth back
force now my German is terrible my
English is terrible my science language
is no existing everything is terrible
now
my name is Philip org I'm a German DJ
I've come to Los Angeles to be a music
man to make people dance around Lawrence
are you from Arabia Lawrence of Arabia
British Beatlemania Ole Miss john glenn
liston it's better said I did discover
YouTube from a nice a nice video of a
kitten cat it was like my mama's like a
few like amoeba top diversify here now
and show so me it is like a cat who look
like he's like playing like a song like
pepper dip a pop Boop but it's not a
real cat and then I start to make music
videos as of course I'm a musician so
then I did uploading those music videos
and this this was like this I think
YouTube is excellent for music promoting
because it is so easy you know it is
like what you say like a crock pot you
know you just take your little beans and
your meat and your Tomatoes you dumped
in the caca pot and then you go fishing
you know you return for hour later what
you have done this is what is you to
Rocco Omega uploads of music I go by
signal push up turn around hey views
now I love many of the YouTube videos
I think SIA great I have learned about
and didn't make some things with Daily
Grace Daily Grace and Hannah Hart also
watch out she is cool you know and I
like olives it's a big boys are nice and
the tiny boys and girls also what is
some other ones I like a mystery guitar
man watch out it's a mystery and here
comes music you know so I like that but
I like everyone not only youtubers I
like other people's like Dirk Nowitzki
and Reggie Watts
watch your pants those one day
everything explodes when he's coming I
just decide you know in November all the
riders they have a thing they're like
hey it's November let's write a novel in
a month and then I said no I'm going to
write it in just some hours so I just
did waken up 7 a.m. you know turn on my
computer
eat some almonds bang bang bang
I finished the novel and then I said hey
publisher place
shall we publish it and they said yes
and so I did do it and now I have made
it I did not spell check it as it is too
much time for me to spelling check and
asking people are ok with it I hope
sorry it's in the title soap jimsy is a
travel adventure squirrel and so tryin
to Chinese noodle the novel I did write
in 8 hours and 8 minutes no planning
page 53 stop do not marry this turkey
from the Chinese noodle Wallace did
comes these words Tim Z is the adventure
squirrel this is a choosing your own
adventure novel I did write it in 8
hours and I did have some help of people
that was like I was live streaming it
you know and people would say hey
perhaps perhaps his friend is is a drunk
beer with chainsaw arms and so I said
yes and he is now in the story also I
keep doing the beat back
jerk is the best thing in all of the
world and all of the sings you know let
us say you like some copy cakes and you
go to a store you like these are really
nice cupcakes
yeah well the Nutri scholar can say jerk
shall you make a copy cake and he would
be like great he make it for you he mail
it to you guess what is best copy cake
in a world he require no practice to be
expert in all of things in the world you
want to a nice yoga session called Eric
he can learn and he can know it he's
like he is the best he everyone is like
number four hundred dear kiss number one
two three four five six seven eight nine
it's nothing to Rolling Stones you know
and I I sing say okay would you know but
I'd be honest you could like any song
and I would say immediate it can be
choppy sticks it can be Miley Cyrus's
what does who know what party in my USA
you know it doesn't matter if Duke say
we do it we do it so he liked this tune
and I said dear I love you in applet on
way I know makeout grabsy way you know
so what do you like we will do we change
from twerking to jerking watch out t ik
is here everyone run away because you
have no chances
I think number one is number one is make
videos that's number one and then two I
would say megaupload of the videos to
YouTube and then I guess number three is
down stop as you say with Michael
Jackson stopped in Makena for the Bob as
a bet on bum bum people always like
shall I continue
yeah at the ends I yes you know yes like
how much copper yeah more cowbell hello
thanks guys for watching this excellent
video would you like to read the whole
transcript can you read excellent
go to new media rockstars com2 raises
excellent interview to look at the eggs
in photo shoot it shall include me and
and my face and all of the body parts of
me and also you must do it subscribe it
now you are silly person if you do not
do it you are rude I will I just it